virus but we begin with a shooting
attack in a shopping and entertainment
district near phoenix
where at least three people were wounded
the suspected gunman allegedly posted
video
from last night's shooting on social
media cbs news
is only showing you a limited amount of
that footage the suspect
is now in custody jamie yukis reports on
the attack
in glendale arizona in an area that had
recently reopened
after a coronavirus lockdown
damn bro shots rang out at the westgate
entertainment district in glendale
arizona last night
sending people scrambling for cover the
shooting happened
right there literally 100 free from
where we're at
at least three people were struck by the
gunfire
one is in critical condition these
screen shots are from a chilling
snapchat video the alleged gunman posted
leading up to the attack he used what
looks like an assault rifle when he
opened fire into the complex
we are thankful that this was not a
larger scale tragedy
video from the scene shows a person
thought to be the suspect raising his
arms in surrender
and kneeling to the ground as police
approach we were able to take that
suspect into custody
successfully and safely officers locked
down the district for hours and went
door to door to speak to witnesses this
all comes as
arizona businesses have started
reopening in the past two weeks
after the state eased coronavirus
lockdown restrictions
arizona has nearly 15 thousand cases of
coven 19.
if i looked at anything and try to find
a positive out of anything
the pandemic very likely could have
possibly
been a lifesaver tonight because of
smaller crowds
investigators have not identified the
suspect authorities say they are
aware of videos of the alleged shooter
and anyone with those videos should turn
them in
tony